[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
the fine folks over at learn Liberty
today and joining me is an economist and
author and a professor of political
science at Duke University dr. Mike
Munger
welcome to the Reuben report it's great
to be here that introduction just makes
it sound like I'm confused and that's
probably right I thought it made you
sound very professional well I have
several disciplines that I try to
contribute in yeah well we're going to
talk about those several disciplines but
first let's just talk about political
science because I was a political
science major explains a lot I good or
bad good all good oh well good okay I
like to think that I'm one of the few
people that's using political a
political science degree actually to
talk about politics and political
philosophy so my first question to you
would be do you think that political
science right now is sort of needed more
than ever just to understand the basic
philosophies behind so much of the
craziness that we see in public
discourse these days well for two
reasons one political science studies
engineering but it studies the
engineering of rules and we tend to have
this idea that what we need is better
people we're probably not going to get
better people but we may need is better
rules the question is how to try to do
that the other thing political science
does is look at some of the ethical
questions that have plagued given beings
for the last 3,000 years so I see
political science as being a kind of
ideal liberal arts degree that combines
an analysis and ethics but of course I
think and I would I'm a political
science professor that we need more
political science but I really do worry
that people just think we can ignore the
Constitution of the living Constitution
we'll change it to interpret the way
that we want it we don't understand
enough about rules to be able just to
change it willy-nilly and have it turn
out well so I like what you said there
about that we can't change people that
much a lot of people seem to think that
that's what politics should be right we
should actually change the way your
opinions are about very personally held
things through public Hollywood choose
the new Messiah
everybody Morocco Obama was going to be
the new Messiah he got a new
Peace Prize after he'd been in office
for seven months yeah so the this
emphasis on this next person is going to
be the one and you see it worldwide but
it's a little surprising to see the u.s.
succumb to it also yeah
so as a you do consider yourself a
libertarian right you ran as a laborer
trying to get to that and I am I am
certainly a libertarian and in the sense
that I am NOT a Republican okay and I
want to unpack the differences between
that and then talk about sort of the
ever-changing label thing which is sort
of becoming meaning at the moment
so with all the political philosophies
out there do you sense that some of the
freedom stuff is taking root right now
because I it's think to me things are
going crazy right now but I sense that
Liberty reason getting back to some of
the Constitution stuff I do sense people
talking about a little bit more now than
perhaps two years ago well right I had a
bunch of colleagues who after Trump was
elected and colleagues at Duke yeah so
political science professors and other
people on the Left who would come into
my office and sheepishly say you know
you were right all this stuff about we
need to worry about the constitutional
powers of the president when george w
bush was president they were worried
with barack obama they said i don't mind
so much as long as my guy is in charge
that's the point
and i won't always be in charge so what
you might want best is a dictator that
you can pick right that's not how it
works
what i means that we have to have rules
and it's very frustrating the
constitution builds in conflict and
barack obama in many ways was a terrible
president in trying to negotiate things
with the congress he would prefer to go
make speeches yeah he liked that messiah
thing so i do think that a lot of people
on the left are much more worried now
about sort of traditional constitutional
protections of freedom of speech and
about the separation of powers so the
number of them have actually said you
know those federalist papers that's
really interesting aren't they yes
welcome back yeah
so when george w bush was signing
executive actions i assume you were
basically against them when when barack
obama was signing life so you were
basically against the my zoom
you're not thrilled right now with the
amount that that Trump is done but
that's really interesting to me that
your colleagues on the left are suddenly
gone oh now I get it you know we have
people on the left now fighting for
states rights because they don't want
the feds coming in and closing sanctuary
cities which i think is like what a
phenomenal flip I can't help but
gleefully remind them you know you told
me that was code for racism but now
you're for states rights because you're
worried about medical marijuana you're
worried about same-sex marriage states
rights it's true was misused by
advocates of segregation that's
absolutely right Hitler was a vegetarian
it doesn't mean that all vegetarians are
Nazi doesn't mean that all states rights
people are racist states rights is an
important part of federalism and it
means that we can accomplish some things
in the States so I have this
conversation all the time on the show
but also privately because I'm a big
states rights guy and and what people
will say to me sometimes even just a
conversation I was having this weekend
some of the saying to me well I just
don't trust that the states will do the
right thing that the southern states
will do all these backwards social
things or all that stuff now I've had
many people on here including Randy
Barnett who I'm sure you're familiar to
talk about the foot vote and that you
should leave States and take your
economic value and your personal value
and your family and move somewhere else
in that that's wonderful and
irritability that's the beauty of
America do you think that's a sound
enough argument for states right well it
that you can just pick up and go it has
it helps a lot it takes a while to do
that I guess I would argue for the way
that we've elaborated states rights
which is we take the first ten
amendments to the Constitution the Bill
of Rights and we apply those also to
state laws through incorporation through
the Fourteenth Amendment so there are
limits on what the states can do but
other than that yes the states can have
all sorts of different things and the
9th and 10th amendments both reserved a
bunch of powers to the states and that I
think the expansion through the commerce
clause and we're sort of getting down in
the weeds but the expansion of federal
powers at the expense of the states has
been one of the catastrophes in
constitutional jurisprudence and I hope
we'll go back in the other direction
but it doesn't seem like that president
Trump's appointment seemed to be more
like 10th amendment skeptics right well
even just in the last week you know
there's some it's a little confusing
what the truth is but it sounds like
sessions may go after the states because
of medical marijuana these are the
things that I just simply don't
understand if the Republicans or
conservatives or the Trump people
whatever whatever that is wouldn't you
want to take a stand that would that
would make some logical consistency
you'd get decent liberals to go yeah
you're doing the right thing well
because that would mean that you would
be operating on principle and not
politics and I guess I had hoped and I'm
now disappointed that our Republican
friends have not done that all they've
done is what they decried in others when
Obama was president okay now we're in
power and we'll do all this stuff that
we rightly criticized Obama for doing
that means that you have no principle at
all what does that tell you about power
in general like that the second they get
this and it's still a little unclear to
me what sessions is doing about the
medical marijuana thing but if you were
to do anything other than respect states
rights it shows me that once you have
power you just suck more power I think
it's it isn't inevitable there used to
be a norm of deference to the
Constitution and to some extent of
forbearance or toleration so you know
I'm Catholic clearly I think that that's
the correct religion all others are
mistaken I also think that you get to
want whatever you get to believe
whatever you want it's that that second
norm of toleration that's being wiped
away and we're going to end up just
being a bunch of competing interest
groups so I don't think it's inevitable
that power is so seductive but there if
other people it's like standing in line
if a bunch of us come up to something
and there's more of us than can get
through it we just automatically stand
in line but if somebody cuts in line you
say you can't do that but if a bunch of
people cuts in line the line breaks so
our the norm of toleration that we
actually require that this sense that
it's wrong to do this just because it's
wrong even though I have the power
that's breaking down and I don't think
that institution can easily be rebuilt
yeah do you see that breaking down in
sort of every facet of public life right
now like
for a moment before we started we were
talking about the media and it seems
that mainstream media norms are
crumbling and we have activists
activists that are now masquerading as
journalists this is a huge problem well
for a very long time in a number of
different professions that were sort of
guild rules that is I have to act as a
professional law or I will lose the
respect of my colleagues and that
respect comes from doing things the
right way not taking positions that are
correct according to the liberal or
conservative catechism it's doing things
the right way it's actually doing real
reporting instead both sides are
substituting what Stephen Colbert called
truthiness yeah which is there's an
essential truth that exists irrespective
of the facts and the facts are not
evidenced they're examples that makes a
world of difference
you're quarreling with my examples I
have other ones well no if you say
something that's not a fact that means
you're not a professional yeah you
should be embarrassed that's what we're
losing is those norms of professionalism
where do you think that started or when
do you think excited the most famous
incident was dan Rather and some
producers at CBS with the letters from
the Alabama National Guard about George
W Bush and the letters were provided by
someone he said he'd found him in some
files but when you looked at him it was
pretty clear that they couldn't have
been done on an IBM Selectric typewriter
there a proportional font they had the
wrong size footnotes and they should
have backed off it don't made a mistake
mm-hmm they did they doubled down and
said well but there's an essential truth
here and so what happened was and this
is the origin of the pajamas media the
CBS producer said something he thought
was true that turned out to be true in a
way he didn't expect which was who are
you going to believe
CBS there's a guy in his basement
wearing pajamas well it turns out that
the guy in the basement wearing pajamas
is pretty good at fact-checking and so
but it didn't start there
but that was a catalyzing moment where
people said to me CBS News Edward Armour
oh this is as
as professional as it gets and they
substituted their own ideological
judgment for any sort of concern about
facts the guy in the basement seems to
be getting more powerful these days do
you view that as a net good the power's
asymmetric we cannot discover truth what
we can do is impeach falsehood so the
guy in the basement is pretty good at
checking and seeing if there's something
contradictory to a claim that you've
made and what that means is that no one
can believe anything now because there's
always someone who's checking on it and
saying maybe making this up oh there
there there there's a quote in a tweet
and it's - a link and they just assert
something it becomes a fact yeah this is
a problem so it's a profitable property
there yeah so it's a terrible problem so
then how do you as a political science
professor someone that's trying to frame
this for young minds how do you give
them something that they don't walk out
of your class at the end of the semester
and go oh man we're screwed or maybe
they do and that's how you eventually
fix things
well I I want them to walk out of class
saying we could be screwed we have an
obligation to try to act against this
and one of those obligations is to do
the right thing even when it's not in
our self-interest and so one of my
students from a while back from Duke is
a guy named Brendan Nyhan
at Dartmouth College who writes a lot
about this sort of problem and so I
think if you if readers are interested
if you look at Brendan ion's work on
this question of I think there is some
hope in this direction but if it's going
to we're going to have to enlist the aid
of more of the mainstream media and the
problem that you have is you may just
lose the ratings war yeah if you're not
interesting and provocative have we
already crossed that point it seems to
me we that the election got us to sort
of parity between the online media and
the mainstream media like that night it
sort of became equal and now at this
point I think the online media actually
has more influence and that's sort of
why the clickbait style and and the some
of the stuff that we've seen with CNN
over the last couple weeks that's why
it's gotten crazier because they're
they're just grasping
for the last bit of relevancy let's put
a more hopeful spin and if it is true
remember we talked about states rights
were misused by segregationists well
it's true that some of the power for
curation of the mainstream media was
misused and when I we no longer trust
them but it's much easier now to produce
content and I bit self-serving but your
show is a sign that people are actually
willing to spend more than three or four
minutes or 140 characters and try to
understand things so there is this
desire to know if not the truth at least
the nuance of the different claims yeah
and the ability to leapfrog what you can
just put something up on YouTube you get
subscribers and to some extent that's
going to determine something like
ratings so you don't have to go through
these institutions that until now have
meant that only a relative few people
could participate in the conversation
yeah but do you fear the Wild West
Factor but I do the best job I can but
people sometimes say to me Dave you're
the only person I trust and I go man
this is a huge problem I'm doing the
best I can truly we're in a transition
yeah and the Wild West
actually wasn't that bad in a way
there's a book by Terry Anderson and PJ
Hill called the not so wild wild west
they talked about the California Gold
Fields and the fact that people came up
with ways of allocating property rights
and adjudicated disputes so for a little
while yes it was bad but people realize
what just sucks we can do better than
this right and they organized themselves
so I think within five years we're going
to look back on this time as a time of
transition but not as a time of
catastrophe new institutions are going
to emerge because the ability to curate
and provide news that people can rely on
as much fun as it is just always to be
outraged I think we're going to come up
with new institutions because the stakes
are too high
yeah and I hope we do I mean as someone
that's an outsider for that crumbling
thing which I think it should crumble I
do want some new institutions to exist
because otherwise we're just going to
filter ourselves into into total
distance from each other in a way the
catastrophe that is the Trump
administration
it means that a whole lot of people it
happens that editor for The Weekly
Standard Bill Kristol is a friend of
mine his daughter went to Duke I know
not a fan of Trump not really a fan of
Trump yeah he attends a conservatism
that should be great he's got a
Republican Congress Republican president
but he's saying no principle is more
important than power
[Music]
you